hey it's alex and today i'm going to be
watching behind tasty giant raindrop
cake starring yours truly it's been a
minute since i watched this video i mean
i don't usually watch my old videos but
i have to say if i were to watch it
behind tasty this is my favorite one
just because i think it's so funny
no i'm just trying to help you don't
show your boobs
off to a great start i am that much of a
klutz in real life and originally i was
supposed to do this video with rea she
ended up having a lot of shoots to do
herself so she didn't have the time to
do it so instead we just settled for her
popping in to help me every once in a
while i hadn't even eaten a raindrop
cake before
i knew like what it was i want to say
this was one of if not the hardest
behind tasties that we did all right
let's make it rain
wow it's so funny like in these videos
you see how like light and fun i am in
the beginning and then it slowly goes
like
more and more dark also i got a lot of
comments being like people pronouncing
agar i don't know how it's supposed to
be pronounced i still didn't figure that
out two minutes two minutes we gotta
wait for two you know i still sing this
song a lot of times
like whenever i have to wait for two
minutes it's the first thing i do this
may be the easiest one we've done yet
although we haven't really done anything
yet so maybe i shouldn't
be saying anything yeah you should
already
so we're already running to a few
problems but one of the biggest problems
was finding the right type of agar agar
to use in this recipe because again
there's only like three ingredients in
this whole thing but it's more about
like the method that ended up being
tricky than like the ingredients
themselves we're taking a little field
trip my car
this is real like we had to go
to the
actually no we had to go to a few
different kinds
it took a whole day to find
the right agar
i'm gonna try at least you know i'm
having fun while making this thing
though you know
this is gonna make it much easier to
measure out properly wow look at me i'm
so smart
figuring things
oh gosh and i do remember this there's
so much math that went into this recipe
it's like
division and multiplication oh my god
and i hate math not only do i have to do
all these different things come up with
this recipe figure it out film a video
be on camera now i gotta do math
are you kidding
i didn't sign up for this the point of
the raindrop cake is to have this very
clear cake so if you have too much agar
then it's not going to be clear the cake
is going to be too dense it won't be
like a raindrop but if you have too
little of the agar then the cake won't
hold its shape it was just very hard and
more than my simple brain could handle
mind you it's like day two or three and
i'm still just on the small raindrop
cake i haven't even moved on to the
giant raindrop cake
[Music]
and that's what's also difficult is that
like
each time in between there was like a
hour waiting time so it was like pushing
the schedule back and back and back so i
was getting more pressure yeah i feel
like it's
rain dropping you can tell i hate it
like i can't even hide my disgusting try
to do the giant one it would be like the
purpose oh also yeah another factor is
like to get that nice raindop shape we
had to get a specific bowl at night we
were like going out to different like
stores to find the right bowls we're
gonna make a little bouquet yeah so some
of the raindrops cakes you see online
like the reason they look nice is
because they have like little
decorations in them so i decided to put
the flowers in them because they're
meant to be like at the top like when
you flip the cake over them they'll be
at the top
but
it didn't work spoiler alert
because you're supposed to like thicken
it first i don't really know i don't
know what i was doing this whole time
don't stay at the bottom they're a
little more agar than a normal size cake
would so i guess we'll just start i know
i was definitely very stressed out at
this point because i i was you know
during these days i was like i really
don't think i can do this because it was
just not working i hadn't even had one
successful try
it's such a simple process obviously
it's really tricky and hard but like the
process itself is so simple it's just
like boiling down the
agar and the water that i was just so
over it by like day six i was just like
how many more pots of water do i have to
boil
it's not flipping
so that was also tricky
for some reason
the molds that i bought these bowls they
had like a weird surface on the inside
and it didn't allow for the raindrop
cake to slip out nicely they were just
all clinging to the bowl for some reason
so here you can see i'm like
dipping the bowl in hot water
to hopefully like loosen up the edges
again as the days go on i get more and
more crazy because i'm just like going
mentally and one tablespoon we'll have
our rainbow cake the power of
positivity there was a lot i had to
clean up this episode i remember that it
was like water everywhere the final day
i think i had called claire who was the
culinary
head at the time and
i spoke with her for like an hour
we finally came to the conclusion that
for some reason the agar needed to be
dissolved first in just cold water and
then to boil it it was just like little
variations like that but they ended up
making all the difference so thank you
claire for your help
[Laughter]
if you know me you know i sing like at
very weird moments
it literally looks like
oh my god i'm even sweating now like my
palms
[Music]
so let me just say
i know
that this raindrop cake wasn't actually
as clear as it maybe was supposed to be
but
we had realized after days of this that
it wasn't really going to get that much
clearer and especially with like the
math of being a giant raindrop cake we
didn't really think it was possible
because it just needed more agar to be
able to hold itself what i was going for
at this point was just like that shape
and the hold and the texture more than
like the complete clarity but it is a
little deceiving like the video of it
because if you like looked at it from
different angles it was a lot more clear
than it looks there what was the
stressful part was like once we finally
nailed it because i did not want to have
to do it again
we only had like a few minutes to get
all the shots we needed because
naturally a raindrop cake because it is
so delicate it will just start to
disintegrate
on its own so i had like a few minutes
to get all of my shots for the tasty
video
and all the shots for the behind tasty
video that nathan was making and like
the final words like everything we had a
few minutes to get it all once i took
off this bowl and saw that it worked
i am still shocked that they let us end
on that note that's all i have to say
about that wait
you know i love watching that video back
because it's so funny to me and
i'm just glad i get to watch it back and
not have to do it back it brings back
all the good memories from doing those
videos the moments where i got to hang
out with my friends and laugh with the
other producers and challenge myself to
do something that i hadn't done before
that is what i take back from the videos
well that was me watching back the
behind tasty giant raindrop cake episode
there's only one way to end it
what
oh yes
[Music]